Unreal Engine a suite of developer tools
for building world-class interactive 3D
experiences it was created by Tim
Sweeney at epic games in 1995 is written
in C plus and was originally designed
for first person 3D shooter games today
it's used to build AAA games like
fortnite for visual effects and TV shows
like the Mandalorian VR simulation and
medicine and aviation in addition to
Independent games by developers like you
at its core the engine provides a
standard architecture for implementing
highly complex requirements like 3D
rendering physics animation Ray tracing
and a lot more all this magic is
accessible via its visual editor where
you can easily create levels and fill
them with 3D objects called actors than
to make a game interactive it provides a
visual scripting language called
blueprint where you can program game
logic without ever writing your own C
plus code when your creation is complete
unreal can package it for desktop mobile
and virtually any game console or VR
platform to build the next AAA billion
dollar game franchise right now download
the epic games launcher install on real
engine and create a new project first go
down to the content drawer which is
where all the game assets are saved from
here we can right click to create a new
level then from the top nav bar add our
first actor to it like a shape that the
player can collide with it's currently
invisible but we can change the view
mode to wireframe to view its geometry
and notice how it's been added to the
outliner here which is a hierarchy of
your game objects if we select the cube
we can now modify its properties its
physical shape is defined by a mesh
which we can modify in isolation by
clicking it to make it look cool though
we need to apply a different material to
the mesh we could create a new material
from scratch or use one from the
built-in starter content looks cool but
now we need some lighting we could add a
light actor or better yet use the
environment light mixer to quickly add
lights and atmosphere to the level now
we need to create some land let's go
into landscape mode choose a material
like Moss or gravel then create it we
now have a flat surface to walk on and
we can sculpt it into mountains and
valleys with the brush tool now go back
to selection mode select the cube and
tick the box to simulate physics when
you click play you should now see the
cube roll down the hill but a game needs
a controllable player so let's add a
character actor to the scene and now
it's time to do some actual programming
with blueprints create a Gamo blueprint
to define the rules and scoring system
of your game then another blueprint for
the character then give the character a
brain with a controller blueprint if we
open that blueprint we can start coding
game logic here in the event graph begin
play runs when the level first loads
while tick runs on every frame now there
are tons of built-in functions that you
can run in response to these events like
print string we can execute this
function on every frame by connecting it
to the tick event and now when we run
the game It Won't Stop Printing hello
world with blueprints you connect events
nodes functions and variables together
to create interactive game elements this
has been Unreal Engine in 100 seconds
hit the like button and let me know if
you want to see a full unreal tutorial
in the comments thanks for watching and
I will see you in the next one